le mouvement moi aussi a révélé au monde
des prédateurs sexuels comme james dean
il y en a un troisième qui pourrait être
même pire et il est canadien
[Applaudissements]
piranha gold de winnipeg il a bâti un
empire international de la mode aux
bahamas où il possède un palace l'homme
qui a aujourd'hui 79 ans aurait fait des
dizaines de victimes d'agressions et
d'exploitation sexuelle certaines
d'entre elles étaient des adolescentes
héros fille mercy ce nom si une femme
disait non moins que ce soit des
employés la drogue est un camion de la
préparer pour lorsque nagui serait prêt
à monter avec elle à nos collègues de
l'émission fifth estate à sibiti enquête
depuis plus de 10 ans sur piranha games
qui vient d'être arrêté
nagl a tout fait pour les empêcher de
révéler cette histoire qu'il nie
complètement sa mairie salle certaines
de ces images sont difficiles à regarder
pour moi
je voulais montre quand même un lanceur
d alerte est sorti de l'ombre
nul autre que le vidéaste personnel de
piranha gold by gold avait eu lie à
l'avant de l'appareil
oui et couché avec les finis sans mes
images
il allait s'en tirer personne d'autre
autour de nice gold n'a de telles
preuves
je dois vous prévenir que ce reportage
aborde un sujet sensible et que
certaines images peuvent choquer ici
marie maude denis
bienvenue à enquête
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si grave
et non
[Musique]
pylônes à gordes comme vous ne l'avez
jamais vu il m'a dit de tout film est et
des tonnes d'imagés
voici des images inédites que le
vidéaste personnel de piranha games nous
dévoile
quand j'ai été embauché nagl m'a dit que
si jésus est si populaire c'est qu'il
avait une bonne équipe de relations
publiques on travail consistait à tout
filmé et steven ferrals you parle aussi
pour la première fois personne d'autre
n'a de telles preuves
il utilise le pouvoir l'influencé sa
marque pour montrer au monde je suis
pythagore et je contrôle tout ce que je
touche
[Musique]
il savait comment acheter les gens ils
achetaient des politiciens les jeunes
filles se disait qu'elle n'avait pas le
choix
ses trajectoires
[Musique]
j'étais avec ma soeur et ma cuisine au
centre commercial quand nous sommes
passés devant la boutique slim danois
grecque
cette jeune femme a rencontré pythagore
en magasinant dans l'une de ses
boutiques aux bahamas
à l'époque elle n'avait que 14 ans elle
est l'une des cinquante sept femmes qui
font partie du recours collectif déposée
à new york l'an dernier contre nadal est
venu il a primé mesure il voulait
s'assurer que ses clientes porte des
vêtements parfait puis on a pris des
photos à l'avant de la boutique
ce qui est arrivé ensuite est une
histoire souvent tendue aux bahamas il
m'a parlé de mannequinat
puis une femme est venue prendre mon
numéro de téléphone trois jours plus
tard elle m'a dit qu'elle viendrait me
chercher chez moi et à quelle heure être
prête
nous avons dîné
je pensais que nous parlerions de
mannequinat
mais après le repas il m'a dit allons
dans un endroit tranquille pour parler
affaires il m'a amené dans sa chambre à
coucher
[Musique]
[Rires]
ok les archives regorgent d'entrevues ou
pire une à gordes vente sa réussite et
parle de son enfance pauvre née en
finlande il immigre avec ses parents
manitoba en 1952
dès 1967 il a acheté des parts d'une
petite entreprise de vêtements pour
femmes
tand jets de winnipeg
il bâti au fil des décennies un empire
mondial de la mode
nagl internationale mais au fil de son
ascension les rumeurs d'inconduite
sexuelle cours
une accusation de viol abandonné en 1981
et des allégations de harcèlement sexuel
de la part de ses employés dans les
années 90 mais rien n'arrête my world
on est encore bien avant le mouvement
moi aussi piranha garde a pu échapper
aux soupçons à winnipeg mais vous allez
découvrir comment sa fortune et son
pouvoir l'ont aussi longtemps rendu
intouchable aux bahamas dans les années
90 nagada acheter l'extrémité ouest de
la principale île des bahamas la
rebaptisant de son nom
pendant près trois ans steven fair aliot
a été payé pour documenter pratiquement
tout ce qui se passait dans l'univers de
pythagore chaque fois que michael était
aux bahamas c'était la fête le dimanche
il y avait de la nourriture de l'alcool
de la danse de la musique du volley ball
du poker tout le monde buvait il faisait
la fête
nagl présente ses fed comme sa façon de
gâter les femmes de l'île pour leur
permettre de se détendre et s'amuser
mais ce n'était pas les fêtes innocence
qu'il décrivait tout n'était qu'une
horrible illusion riche et 3 ça a
commencé à travailler comme
massothérapeute de nagad en 2009
[Musique]
avec le temps je me suis aperçu que ce
n'était pas juste un travail
c'était un grand bordel riches est dit
qu'il n'aimait pas ce qu'elle voyait
lors des fêtes de nay org
mais il estimé ne pas avoir le choix
j'étais le seul gagne-pain
avec six personnes à charge aux bahamas
aucun autre emploi ne m'aurait payer ce
que nike de me donner ces faits c'était
une façon d'attirer des filles pour que
monsieur n'à y coucher avec elle
descendait et choisissez une fille
généralement soul il l'attrapé danser
avec elle puis à la fin de la soirée
elle me donnait le signal d'arrêter de
filmer il monte ensuite dans sa chambre
parfois avec deux trois filles ou plus
je me souviens d'une dame yens
qui est monté dans la chambre de michael
elle ne voulait pas couché à l'écrit
elle a réussi à s'enfuir next-up elle
était nue elle a essayé d'escalader la
grille le garde du corps est sorti l'a
empoignée et la ramener à l'intérieur
lors de ces fêtes c'était fréquent
certaines des femmes choisies par
michael ne pouvait pas fuir
même si elle aurait voulu et vos films
et celle ci une femme disait nombre des
employés l'a droguée puis il la
préparait pour lorsque nagai serait prêt
à monter avec elle les barmen avait
l'habitude de verser la drogue dans le
vert des femmes en particulier celles
qu'il savait que michael davis
les collègues de siby si on parlait à
deux autres femmes qui ont affirmé avoir
vu de la poudre blanche au fond de verre
tendu par les barmen de nay garde et
quatre femmes ont dit croire qu'elles
avaient été drogués avant d'être violé
une femme est venue dans le quartier où
nous passions la plupart de notre temps
elle nous a dit que si on le voulait on
pourrait aller en haïti dans la
poursuite civile contre nagad cette fin
mais la victime numéro trois c'est
également sa première entrevue télévisée
elle dit avoir rencontré nagad en 2011
n'était jamais allée de ce côté de lille
c'était fascinant tous ces paniers
magnifique tout était si luxueux je
n'avais jamais vu ça
elle m'a demandé si je voulais
rencontrer monsieur marigold lorsque je
suis entré dans la pièce il m'a invité à
m'asseoir il m'a offert un verre de vin
que je n'ai jamais fini
après avoir répondu à quelques-unes de
ces questions j'ai commencé à avoir la
nausée je me sentais malade comme si je
n'étais pas moi même
il m'a entraîné dans une chambre il y
avait des draps des fleurs je me
souviens qu'il y avait comme un grand
miroir au plafond il y avait une vue sur
la baie on aurait dit que la chambre
était entourée d'eau il m'a invité à
m'asseoir sur le lit il me tirer par la
manche
je n'étais pas à l'aise confuse j'avais
la tête qui tournait craignez de vomir
il a commencé à me pousser
et j'ai dit stop stop stop
tout tournait autour de moi il a
commencé à baisser mon pantalon et il
m'a pénétré
selon la poursuite civile pirna garde a
violé les victimes numéro 1 et 3
alors qu'elle n'avait que 14 et 15 ans
respectivement à de nombreuses reprises
j'ai vu des filles à qui on avait promis
qu'elles deviendraient des mannequins
vedettes mais c'était faux après en
avoir abusé sexuellement il les oubliait
elles disparaissaient aussi vite qu'elle
est apparue
nos collègues de l'émission de faire
tester et a subi six enquêtes sur des
allégations semblables depuis un premier
reportage en 2010 ces fêtes n'avait rien
à voir avec le maquillage
il s'agissait simplement de lui procurer
des femmes parmi lesquelles choisir pour
link et michel et alonso ont travaillé
pour na garde aux bahamas où il gérait
sa propriété c'est là qu'ils ont
rencontré une jeune dominicaine maribel
rodriguez elle devait avoir 17 ans elle
ne parlait pratiquement pas anglais elle
croyait être là pour devenir mannequin
car un soir les médis qu'un événement a
affolé maribel rodriguez elle a paniqué
et s'est mise à hurler et à pleurer
elle s'est réfugiée chine quand de faire
tester à raconter ces événements en 2010
l'avocat nagl envoyé une déclaration de
maribel rodrigues indiquant que son
séjour avait été agréable et amusant est
que michael était un vrai gentleman
[Musique]
j'ai d'abord rencontré mais robert
rodriguez lors d'un voyage en république
dominicaine en 2012 c'est elle avec le
bustier bleu selon le vidéaste maribel
rodriguez a rapidement été embauché par
l'entreprise de nagl après s'être porté
à sa défense en 2010
ensuite elle est devenue une sorte d'
assistante personnelle
souvent c'était la plus proche de nicole
j'ai fini par la connaître elle m'a
parlé de son fils il de sa mère en
république dominicaine mairie berre
l'étang rouge pour attirer les filles et
les garder dans son entourage
tiger leur promettait des choses pour
elle en particulier c'était une séance
photo mary bale parcourait le monde avec
n'a gardé son entourage qu'il appelait
ce
ses amis
ce qui pouvait sembler amusant pour
certaines comme mary bale ne l'était
vraiment pas
[Musique]
oui elle voyageait avec lui mais il les
maltraitaient parfois de la violence
verbale mental elle était gardée en
otage on leur prenait automatiquement
leurs passeports qui était placée dans
un coffre fort à la réception pour
pouvoir partir monsieur nagai devait
vous donner son autorisation
c'était de loin le trafic le plus
sinistre le plus intense le plus pervers
est le plus violent que j'aie jamais le
jour lisa abba et greg dobbs 11 sont les
avocats à l'origine du recours collectif
contre peer nagano états unis c'est une
affaire complexe et les enjeux sont très
élevés un réseau de traite
internationale à partir de new york suit
partout dans le monde
des centaines de personnes savaient ce
qui se passait et ont rendu ce
stratagème possédantes new world skies
jusqu'à ce qu'un groupe aux bahamas
décide que cela avait assez duré
selon des témoins c'est devenu si tendue
pour monsieur new york qui l'a embauché
des types pour nous tuer après la pause
une chicane entre piranhas garde et son
voisin aux bahamas dégénère jusqu aux
allégations de tentative de meurtre j'ai
été agressé sur joe beach par neuf
femmes j'ai réussi à fuir
[Musique]
vous vous posez sûrement la même
question comment se fait-il que piranha
et eagle depuis faire ce qu'on lui
reproche aussi longtemps sans jamais
avoir de problèmes aux bahamas
et c'est parce qu'il aurait fait subir à
des femmes et à des adolescentes qui a
marqué le début de la fin pour lui non
c'est plutôt une chicane de voisins est
une drôle d'histoire de vol de sable
dans l'océan
nous sommes en 2011
un grand jour pour la fille de pylônes
heigl qui se marient à winnipeg
[Applaudissements]
la famille les amis sont rassemblés pour
l'occasion
parmi eux le maire de winnipeg de
l'époque sam katz et un invité de marque
venus débat mme therry christie et
l'ex-premier ministre des bahamas et un
ami pylônes à garde toujours le vidéaste
de nagl ce qu'ils veulent faire aliot a
documenté la cérémonie lagarde
connaissait christie depuis des années
il disait qu'il l'avait aidée à obtenir
sa citoyenneté aux bahamas leur relation
remonte au moins à 1992 comme le
démontre cette lettre envoyée par nagada
cru astier alors qu'il n'était encore
que simple ministre nayla lui rappelle
ses dons de dizaines de milliers de
dollars
il lui demande de l'aider pour ces
petits problèmes d'intendance dont sa
demande répétée pour étendre sa
propriété en bord de mer sur des terres
de la couronne
le monde entier s'est construit sur une
main qui est de l'autre écrit tiger
en 2011 perry christie se représente
comme premier ministre avec piranha guns
écouté ta gueule s'est rendu à las vegas
avec des filles peric aussi voici une
photo de l'un de leur dignité
vous avez nice gold kerry christie et
tout au fond à droite c'est bizarre
hélas une liasse de billets glissés dans
son soutien-gorge négoce attribue la
victoire de christie
[Musique]
près de 30 ans se sont écoulés depuis
cette lettre de pylônes à garde
demandant d'étendre sa propriété de bord
de mer
cette saga va révéler bien d'autres
secrets
je ne connaissais pas pris tiger jusqu'à
ce que je découvre ce qu'il faisait pour
dénaturer cette magnifique région
le militant écologiste jodar ville amène
l'équipe de celui-ci par bateau varna
garde qui pour une autre vue de la
propriété déserté nos gants
à l'origine il n'y avait aucune plage
devant cette propriété il n'y avait que
l'océan il a pu aménager tout ça est
utilisé de la machinerie pour draguer
tout ce sable c'est totalement
artificielle
selon 12 avril ce dragage illégal s'est
poursuivie pendant plus de dix ans
doublant la superficie de la propriété
nagl ça me dépasse qu'un type aient pu
faire ça pendant si longtemps en toute
impunité
il savait acheter le silence des gens ça
ne fait aucun doute
nous avons dû lutter non seulement
contre lui mais contre le gouvernement
il aimait se dire plus grand que nature
ils voulaient être reconnues comme un
généreux bienfaiteur des bahamas
parce qu'il adore le pays cette
bienveillance avait un autre bulle
beaucoup plus égoïste le pasteur siby
moss s'est associé à
l'environnementaliste der wiel et aux
voisins de nago le milliardaire
américain louis becker pour faire cesser
le vol de sable par piranha gad
il ne voulait rien entendre c'était sa
volonté ou ma voiture était garée devant
chez moi vers 2 heures du matin ma fille
a vu un véhicule approché lentement deux
hommes ont lancé un dispositif
incendiaire sur ma voiture
c'était terrifiant mais ça ne nous a pas
dissuadé il n'était pas question de se
laisser intimider
[Musique]
j'ai été agressé sur joe beach par neuf
comme j'ai réussi à fuir
l'avocat fritz mif s'est joint au groupe
il est devenu une cible à son tour deux
hommes ont déclaré sous serment dans une
poursuite aux bahamas qu'une en garde
les avait embauché comme assassin
c'est devenu si tendue pour monsieur n'à
gold qu'à mon avis il a embauché des
types très dangereux pour nous tuer ces
déclarations n'ont jamais été prouvées
en cour et michael nie tout en bloc
ils ont laissé faire tout ce qu'ils
voulaient faire pendant des années il
avait carte blanche
[Musique]
puis en 2017 il ya eu un changement de
gouvernement bahamas le docteur hubert
minnis sera assermenté comme quatrième
premier ministre des bahamas
indépendante péristyle hamid pylônes à
gordes perd le pouvoir est au même
moment nagl connaît aussi un revers de
fortune coupable d'outragé au tribunal
le magnat de la mode canadien peter
knight a jusqu'au 21 mars pour payer une
amende de 50 mille dollars
je doute qu'il puisse remettre les pieds
sur cette île sont finir en prison
nagl et est accusée d'avoir enfreint une
ordonnance lui interdisant de continuer
de draguer l'océan jusqu'à la conclusion
d'une révision judiciaire
le public l'entourage de nagad et
d'autres personnes qui en avait long à
dire on commençait à voir que la loi
pouvait s'appliquer
l'avocat fritz mais estime qu'il s'agit
du début de la fin pour pidrn heigl et
ses complices aux bahamas des langues se
sont soudainement délier pour raconter
comment il traitait ses employés
quelques personnes ont commencé à parler
de femmes victimes de violence à
nagasaki d'abus sexuels
au retour le témoignage de l'ex
massothérapeute de pied de l'eiger qui
aurait eu parmi ses tâches connexes
la livraison de pots de vin à des
policiers obama le gouvernement des
bahamas lui avait offert un sanctuaire
d'où diriger son trafic sexuel
en découvrant la face cachée de la vie
de piranha garde qui en passant au
canada a été honorée applaudi décor et
on en revient toujours à la même
incompréhension comment ça se fait que
la police obama s'est pas mise en quêté
sur lui la corruption est une hypothèse
très sérieuse il était minuit passé
lorsque richard ross a accueilli à
l'aéroport de nassau et hormis linz mais
de tels crimes sont noirs il m'a demandé
de le conduire quelque part je lui dis
monsieur il est une heure du matin
où allons nous il m'a dit de prendre une
route de terre près de jazz beach un
autre véhicule les y attendait qu'elle a
reconnu comme celui d'un politicien
important des bahamas
j'ai atteint mes phares et naga et m'a
dit qu'il allait sortir de l'auto de lui
donner quelques minutes j'ai ouvert un
des sacs sur le siège arrière
m et dans chacun des sacs du moins celui
que j'ai ouvert il y avait des liasses
de dix mille dollars us cash
elle soutient qu'un homme est venu
prendre les sacs d'argent sur le siège
arrière
au fil des ans richards ross est devenue
une proche confident de nagad ses tâches
allait bien au-delà de la massothérapie
j'ai apporté de l'argent à nos
politiciens
selon la massothérapeute des hauts
gradés de la police ont aussi reçu des
enveloppes d'argent et les filmer au
kram et m
lorsque des femmes se présentaient en se
plaignant d'avoir été violée victimes de
traite au kidnappés il n'y avait jamais
de rapports de police
monsieur n'à gaida prenait où la femme
vivait et ils étaient soient intimidés
ou payer pour disparaît
natura pour appuyer ses dires les
chiffres us a fourni trois mois ses
propres relevés bancaires de 2016
indiquant le dépôt de près de soixante
mille dollars provenant de la société
mère nagl internationale suivi
d'importants retraits
le comptable lui remettais l'argent
lorsque michael était à l'extérieur du
pays afin qu'elle fasse des paiements à
son nom nos collègues de siby si on
parlait à trois autres personnes qui ont
vu des employés n'aillent leur remettre
de l'argent des politiciens et des
policiers dans un cas nagl l'aurait fait
personnellement qu'est ce n'est sur ces
allégations de corruption
le commissaire de la police royale des
bahamas a refusé de répondre en évoquant
le procès aux états unis
il a toutefois déclaré nous n'avons reçu
aucune plainte concernant la complicité
de quelques officiers de la police
royale des bahamas que ce soit si bbc a
également interrogé l'ex premier
ministre ferry christie par téléphone au
sujet de ses liens financiers avec
pylônes heigl malgré tout risque france
demeure une employée loyal jusqu'à ce
que tout bascule et big n tout match
fort mais c'est devenu trop pour moi
lorsque monsieur n'à gaida décidé
d'organiser un camp pour enfants tiger
qui un jour lors de ce camp richesse a
perdu de vue sa soeur de 13
je me suis immédiatement mise à sa
recherche sur la propriété
j'ai aperçu monsieur n'à gold en menant
ma soeur qui était en maillot de bain
vers sa chambre
je lui ai demandé où elle allait elle
m'a dit monsieur nagai de voeux que je
parade pour lui dans un de ces ensembles
slim
je lui ai demandé de retourner à la
plage quand elle est partie
monsieur nagl et moi avons échangé un
regard et il m'a fait ce petit sourire
en coin
quand il a fait ça sert ce moment-là que
j'ai craqué
parce qu'il ne venait pas juste de
franchir une ligne
il m'avait manqué de respect à tous les
égards il a tout briser un riche et ross
a continué de travail pour nagad mais
elle ne pouvait plus faire louiche est
et quelques autres ont commencé à nous
fournir des renseignements puis des
victimes se sont manifestées en suis
venu à la conclusion que nos gardes
abusé de tout le monde a pu pour les
opposants de nagad aux bahamas le vent
allait commencer à tourner c'était comme
une opération pyramidale qui commençait
par le bas vers le haut
une femme victime de traite je venais
recruteuse elle trouvé quatre femmes qui
en retour en dénicher quatre autres vous
aviez alors un incroyable labyrinthe de
personnes trempant dans cette opération
criminelle
c'est une poursuite explosive qui a
suscité des comparaisons avec jeffrey
epstein en février 2020 les avocats lisa
abba et greg ben stiller estimé avoir
tout ce dont ils avaient besoin
ils ont déposé une poursuite à new york
au nom des dix premières femmes
alléguant de nombreuses agressions
sexuelles commises par piranha gold
supects brand
il avait choisi les bahamas n'est ce pas
il a finit par opérer au vu et au su de
tous le gouvernement des bahamas qui
avait offert un sanctuaire d'où diriger
son trafic sexuel dit pam ont lancé une
action collective contre peter knight
gold cette nouvelle a vite fait le tour
du monde et c'est alors qu'un proche de
nagad s'est manifesté son témoignage
appuyé par des centaines d'heures de
vidéos exclusives dont exposé sans mes
images
il allait s'en tirer personne d'autre
autour de nice gold n'a de telles
preuves
au retour sexe mensonges et vidéo
dans le passé des filles on dit j'ai
trouvé une autre fille je n'aurai pas
besoin de coucher avec margot ce soir le
moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que l'
enquête journalistique de nos collègues
de siby ci ont été longues et
compliquées
ils ont même fait face à des accusations
criminelles en diffamation est ce que
vous allez découvrir ces pylônes à
gordes se serait servi de l'une de ses
victimes pour mettre des bâtons dans les
roues aux journalistes il y à un ordi
femmes ont déposé une première poursuite
contre nagan le fbi et la police de new
york ont fouillé les bureaux de times
square dans le cadre de l' enquête
criminelle sur des allégations de trafic
sexuel
[ __ ] preppy le nagard démissionne de
sa propre entreprise
ces allégations sont entièrement fausses
nous nous défendrons vigoureusement
cela fait partie d'une vicieuse et
malveillantes conspiration menée depuis
dix ans contre nice garde par ses
ennemis l'ennemi
numéro un des gardes qu'il croit être le
conspirateur en chef contre lui et son
voisin aux bahamas le milliardaire louis
becker ils le soupçonnent d'être la
source d'un premier reportage que si bbc
a diffusé en 2010 tous les gestes
dénoncée par ces femmes sont survenus
bien avant l'arrivée de l'ubs est que
nos bahamas l'actrice canadienne est
mannequin et protégées affirme avoir été
violée par noyade à winnipeg en 93
l'ex-employé laursen accuse elle aussi
n'a guère de l'avoir violée lors d'un
voyage d'affaires en 1981 et l'ex
mannequin internationale quasi aline
affirme que nago de la violer dans son
entrepôt de winnipeg en 79
[Musique]
les gens de winnipeg ne le portent plus
aux nues personne d'autre autour de nice
gold n'a de telles preuves
et puis il y a le vidéaste de nago
steven ferrals you je crois que lorsque
les gens se penche au dessus des lois
la meilleure façon de leur prouver le
contraire c'est de le leur faire voir
justement je possède des preuves
irréfutables et je veux maintenant faire
ma part pour rectifier les choses red
knights est adressé aux tribunaux pour
empêcher la diffusion de ces vidéos
ça me désole certaines de ces images
sont difficiles à regarder pour moi je
voulais montrer quand même dingue de
certainement mauvais caractère
[Musique]
il nous a engueulé surtout moi c'était
stressant ferraille au a proposé à louis
bécane l'ennemi juré de tiger de
subvenir à ses besoins et de payer ses
frais juridiques en échange des vidéos
incluant ces images compromettantes
tourner dans le jet privé de najd dans
l'avion il y avait de la nourriture du
poker puis du karaoké un film et après
il y avait la beuverie et la danse
li à l'avant de l'appareil
oui et couché avec les filles
[Musique]
à
cette vidéo a été filmée dans la viande
de nagad en 2012
cette fille mineure je l'avais vu à
l'une des fêtes c'était la première fois
je pense
elle est devenue l'une de ses petites
amies
elle était là pour assouvir les pulsions
de nice gold il se pavaner avec elle au
restaurant il est dans ses réunions
d'affaires
il les appelait ses petites amies qui si
ces à las vegas
il est confus il pense qu'il ya plus de
filles qu'il n'y en a vraiment ici c'est
à londres et nagl est ici au village des
athlètes lors des jeux olympiques de
2012 au cours de la conversation il
découvre qu'elle a 16 ans
ce qui explique ça c'est que dans le
passé des filles on dit j'ai trouvé une
autre fille je n'aurai pas besoin de
coucher avec marguerite ce soir c'est
très typique de la manière de recruter
souvenez-vous de maribel rodriguez 7 ans
à l'époque qui sont des bouleverser un
soir où elle avait trouvé refuge auprès
du maire a été assise à côté de moi en
larmes je les enlacer en lui demandant
ce qui s'était passé
elle m'a dit il faut que je pars d'ici
tiger woods s'est servi de la
déclaration de maribel selon laquelle il
était un parfait gentleman pour intenter
des recours civils et criminels en
diffamation contre nos collègues de siby
6 qui avait fait le premier reportage de
2010 la peine prévue peut aller jusqu'à
cinq ans de prison
entre-temps heigl avait un boucher
maribel rodriguez comme assistant
personnel est le suivaient pratiquement
partout mais en coulisses steven ferrals
you affirme qu'il était clair qu'il
abusait d'elle nous étions à l'hôtel en
chine et j'ai entendu des cris à l'autre
bout du corridor c'était mairie
berlinale gold
ils criaient elles étaient
recroquevillés sur le plancher l'ampleur
totalement effondré ferrario affirme
qu'un jour il a reçu l'ordre de tourner
une entrevue top secrète avec mary bale
elle avait une déclaration à lire j'ai
dû interrompre le tournage à plusieurs
reprises
méribel pleurais je devais l'aider a
prononcé certains mots c'était évident
qu'elle n'avait pas écrit cette
déclaration est la lisait contre son gré
un employé haut placé de navigon qui
était présent ni qu'elle était
contrainte mais quel était le but
d'écrire cela pour elle je me souviens
qu'elle a dit que pythagore était un
gentleman avec elle qu'elle n'avait
jamais rencontré les mais pourquoi
maribel rodriguez aurait accepté de
faire cette déclaration
elle m'a déjà dit que ce travail était
insensé mais qu'elle devait le faire
pour soutenir sa famille je sais qu'elle
envoyait directement son argent à sa
mère et à son fils par amour pour sa
famille en novembre dernier les
accusations criminelles contre ces
missiles ont été suspendus la témoin
vedette nul autre que l'assistante
personnelle de nagad maribel rodriguez a
refusé de témoigner contre les
journalistes
lorsque celui-ci a récemment essayé de
joindre maribel par l'entremise de son
avocat elle a refusé de répondre aux
questions
[Musique]
riche et ross est aussi poursuivie par
nagl qui prétend qu'elle a été payée
pour faire de fausses allégations
il c'est un article du new york times
selon lequel deux de ses accusatrices
aurait été payé pour mentir
personnellement je pense qu'ils ont peur
le clown heigl attaque sa crédibilité
parce qu'elle a reçu un salaire du
groupe d'opposants à nagano bahamas
ainsi qu'un logement qui vaut environ
5000 $ par mois d'avril au québec
peu après avoir déménagé mon ancien
appartement a été visé par des coups de
feu
si j'avais encore été là comme serait-il
arrivé qu est ce qu est devenu mais
enfance affronter cette situation avec
monsieur night c'est cette série ce
qu'est parce que vous ne vous attaquez
pas seulement un multimillionnaire vous
attaquer le gouvernement des bahamas la
police rose
quel est son rôle dans la saga des
gardes complice lanceuse d'alert où elle
même victime board
je me souviens de m'être retourner pour
lui dire je ne me sens pas bien
c'est la dernière chose dont je me
rappelle j'étais dans les vases là la
première fois que j'ai ouvert les yeux
moi je n'avais plus de fanta nous et je
me souviens d'avoir perdu la carte
pendant un moment et quand j'ai ouvert
les yeux à nouveau il était sur moi dans
la poursuite aux états unis
rich ross et la victime numéro 8 nos
collègues de cbe si on parlait à 19
femmes qui disent avoir été violées par
pylône hagarde
elles se disent tout soulagé que les
secrets et les mensonges de tiger soit
enfin révélé
[Musique]
ça évolue
c'est un soulagement je ne me cache plus
je n'ai plus besoin de fuir
j'affronte mon agresseur tu ne m'as pas
seulement fait mal tu as pris une part
de moi que je n'ai jamais voulu te
donner ce n'était pas la première fois
que tu faisais ça je ne suis pas la
première à qui c'est arrivé mais
j'espère que le fait que je parle
fera de sa dernière victime sa dernière
victime qui dirait que c'est une
campagne de salissage parce que j'avais
15 ans à l'époque et lui quel âge avait
t-il c'est sûr qu'il mange parce
qu'aucun homme de 70 ans de dress on
prendra une fille de 15 ans je voulais
être une chef étoilé mais après tout ça
je veux entrer dans la police pour
protéger mes amis ma famille je veux
protéger les enfants dans la rue je veux
que justice soit faite
piranha garde a été arrêté les autorités
américaines veulent le traduire en
justice à new york
le maniaque canadienne la mode peter
knight gare est en prison pitau nagada
comparu cet après midi mme à noter et et
cheville ironie du hasard la même
semaine au pylône hague a été arrêté son
avion privé son trophée était réduit en
pièces pour être vendus à la ferraille
il y a deux semaines pylônes hagen a
essuyé un important revers devant les
tribunaux en fait c'est qu'il demandait
à être remis en liberté en attendant la
procédure d'extradition pour son procès
aux états unis mais la cour a estimé que
le risque qu'ils tentent d'échapper à la
justice était bien réel il reste donc en
prison pour le moment si le reportage de
ce soir vous aux passionnés que vous
êtes curieux d'en apprendre plus tant
sur l'histoire de pylônes à gordes que
sur la démarche journalistique
nos collègues de siby six ans produit un
balado exceptionnelle qui s'appelle yves
aubin design c'est disponible en anglais
seulement pour le moment sur
l'application 6 bis il au sun c'est
certain que l'histoire de piranha games
va revenir dans l'actualité
plusieurs fois au cours des prochains
mois c'est tout pour ce soir au nom de
toute l'équipe merci beaucoup d'avoir
été là je vous donne rendez vous la
semaine prochaine pour une autre enquête
[Musique]